[Musik]
zum letzten mal auf und davon mit tina
und kevin schmid mit den kindern an
ihrer und rohan ihre neue heimat ist
australien
dem ehemaligen tagesschau moderator
hansy erkenntnis er liegt nun in der
demokratischen republik kongo
monika und dreht roma doni mit den
töchtern ja und selina sie in den wüsten
emirat dubai zu hause sandra und dann
können gar die beiden besitzen eine farm
in kanada und claudio candrian und
theres schon bald haben sie ihr
traumhaus auf der karibik insel
margarita
[Musik]
es ist morgen im kongo der neuen heimat
von hansjörg enz eine heimat die den
ehemaligen tagesschau moderator immer
wieder vor rätsel stellt
zum beispiel was die liebe im kongo so
alles klauen sind seines tageshochs sind
bei ihnen in der gefangene das zum abbau
des event die sticks da und lag bei
nacht und nebel aktionen nachbauen oder
mit stach den sinngrund hinterteil für
die leiterin abhängt und man steckt so
sünkel
winkler vom steak muss endlich einmal
versucht damit den verkehr mit
strickleitern arbeitslos
die strickleiter geklaut worden und die
zehnte betrieb vier wochen größere
probleme wenn ihm nicht wieder mal der
weg unter den füßen weg geklaut worden
ist dann geht der ehemalige tagesschau
moderator so oft wie möglich in den kivu
see vor seinem haus schwimmen
schwimmen als ausgleich zum stress seit
14 monaten lebt und arbeitet hansjörg
enz als entwicklungshelfer im kongo er
hat junge journalisten ausgebildet und
bei der modernisierung des lokalsenders
radio mal in der leo mitgeholfen
doch nun steht das größte projekt von
hansjörg eines an radio mal in der leo
der zweitgrößte sender der region soll
ein neues studio bekommen
dafür hat hansjörg enz zwei schweizer
studiotechniker geholt simon schmid vom
schweizer radio und philipp kohler vom
schweizer fernsehen
die beiden sollen ein komplett neues
studio einbauen das aus der schweiz
eingeflogen wurde letzte woche ungefähr
hoffen und das tor völlig neues studio
entstand das man nominal auf ramsauers
jahres will szenario zwei striche an dem
ergebnis können sich bürger einstand und
da laut eigentlich auch danach wie sie
ja aber auch wenn ich rede jetzt nicht
weg
und das wirkt lange nicht war doch gar
nicht darf ihre tochter erstellende
darauf leute immer auf ob diesmal alles
klappt oft genug ist es anders gekommen
sie spiegeln gedanke mit davon gekommen
[Musik]
es ist sommer geworden in kanada bei
sandra banken gar ein stressiger winter
liegt hinter den frischgebackenen
fahrern 129 kälber sind in den
vergangenen monaten auf die welt
gekommen
zusammen mit den 134 mutterkühen grasen
sie friedlich auf der weide das gesamte
kapital der beiden
[Musik]
dafür planen danke nun neue sorgen die
heuernte scheint dieses jahr ins wasser
zu fallen
[Musik]
start über 15 cm wasser
das ist einfach verlorenes geld
fast die ganze häuser song über hat es
geregnet in kanada das sieht einfach
nein geschäft nichts los ist mit also
schnitte es ist nicht so dramatisch wien
ist völlig neu
wenn man denn doch ein drittel der etwa
habe ich auf vermögen nach dem körper
verkauft gerade großes stück weg und
dieser die kosten für das next chancen
um gewässer
duncan macht sich sorgen ob das geld
reichen wird das budget des pharma
ehepaars aus dem zürcherischen weiningen
ist knapp
da kommt die gute nachricht von sandra
gelegen
sie hat für einen tag pro woche einen
job als sekretärin in einer lastwagen
firma gefunden
es stimmt tatsächlich standard anfangs
gratis sind muss eine sprache der status
- nämlich auch dann ausgezahlt
sicherlich ist das klima mit der
lastwagen
[Musik]
in alice springs in australien ist für
einmal alles anders
diener schmid hat einen job gefunden und
arbeitet nun regelmäßig tour guide kevin
schmid ist für ein paar tage zu hause
[Musik]
er der normalerweise fünf bis sechs tage
pro woche auf tour ist hat endlich
einmal zeit für die familie
[Musik]
der hausmann shop ist für kate eine ganz
neue herausforderung
ruf lumen nach dem buch machen ich weiß
ja so nicht so nervös aber das guthaben
im warm up für momo nicht in den ganztag
machen na ja ich hatte während kate sich
als hausmann durchschlägt arbeitet
diener im größten shoppingcenter von
alice springs zwei bis dreimal pro woche
hilft diener in einem sandwich schlagen
als mädchen für alles aus
für die gelernte pflegefachfrau nicht
gerade der traumjob
ja das könnte jetzt schlimm ist
definitiv
spieltag schaffen und da bisher nicht
pcs haben wir reden mal unbedingt darum
was ich schaffen sondern ich befördern
ich einen tag pro woche kann unterliegt
sie kann hier beschaffen
natürlich das mache für diener ist der
job eine übergangslösung so bald wie
möglich wie sie wieder im krankenhaus
arbeiten
doch dafür braucht sie eine happige
englisch prüfung und die hat sie bereits
einmal vermasselt
[Musik]
cabot genießt die wenige zeit mit seinem
sohn hat
[Musik]
der modus ist für die dann lohnt sich
noch entwickeln
[Musik]
das ist ganz natürlich zu sagen welche
keine bringen
sie stiegen die kicker mit dem 1
[Musik]
es ist ein heißer morgen in der wüste
dubais
[Musik]
seit acht monaten eben sonys im
wüsten-emirat selina und klarer geht
seit knapp fünf monaten in die schule es
ist ein ständiges kommen und gehen beim
adonis im race pilot reto kommt gerade
aus indonesien nach hause
während drehte den schlaf nachholt fährt
monika jeden morgen die kinder zur
internationalen schule der einstieg für
teheran selina war hat ganz ohne
englischkenntnisse die ungewohnte
schuluniform und so viele neue
kameradinnen und kameraden
[Musik]
jahr als erste stunde ist heute
mathematik sie kommt mittlerweile gut
mit in der schule
[Musik]
während klara in der mathematik stunde
schwitzt kühlt sich selina im
schuleigenen pohl ab heute ist
überlebenstraining angesagt die kinder
sollen sich so lange wie möglich über
wasser halten und als besondere
herausforderung sich auch noch im wasser
ausziehen
sarah hat ihre mathematik aufgabe gelöst
die lehrerin ist sie zufrieden mit den
fortschritten der achtjährigen
sie ist im großen und ganzen ein
schüchternes mädchen und ich denke das
muss man einfach auch so akzeptieren und
sie da so in ihre rolle so lassen und
uns sowieso sein lassen wie sie
eigentlich ist aber sie ist sehr
glücklich gemacht auch durch einen sehr
zufriedenen eindruck dass sie noch ein
bisschen zurückhaltend ist denke ich ist
auch nicht verwunderlich wenn man sich
überlegt was da so in den letzten
monaten auch selina ist unterdessen
wieder in ihrem klassenzimmer ihre
lehrerin miss lugner bespricht mit ihr
eine arbeit die sie über nelson mandela
machen soll
ich bin stolz auf sie ist viel besser
geworden nicht celina und industriepark
begabung und dargestellt da auch der
dritte nach dem kampf nachricht ist dass
prosieben die flyers schwarze das ganze
die beiden mädchen scheinen ihre
anlaufschwierigkeiten überwunden zu
haben
[Musik]
in venezuela auf der isla margarita ist
bei claudio candrian und theres bohnet
neben katzen noch ein weiterer nachwuchs
dazu gekommen
der dreimonatige findel hund reißen
claudio country als ganz große liebe
[Musik]
denn
ja der herr da wächst hohen vorschlägen
bin ja froh einen so freiwillig an
aufräumt und wohnt und kaley cuoco der
bischof sein wird ist zum werkstück sie
wo man nachsehen
doch wie geht es mit dem großen traum
der beiden vorwärts claudio und theres
fahren wieder mal zur baustelle ihres
hauses
was vor monaten mit landkauf ärger und
unwilligen bauarbeitern begann hat
unterdessen tatsächlich form angenommen
der rohbau des traumhauses der beiden
steht man mag es kaum glauben
[Musik]
doch der ärger bleibt ein ständiger
begleiter denn nur langsam geht es
vorwärts ja jetzt doch zu hoch oder
vielmehr verdoppelt
einfach organisieren es nicht grauenhaft
europa werden beim brot wenn dir so
schafer würden wir die erde
das ist nicht viel auf den aquarium hat
wünscht aquarium
genau dies habe sie auch da geht es den
cookie kühlschrank in dieser
schlafzimmer
da geht es natürlich noch stärker das
ist denn nicht wenige sind ja das gibt
der doppelstöckige und das konnten aus
holz besetzten arena
da warten treffen da wird ein architekt
mit holz
seit neun monaten wird nunmehr am haus
gebaut
dieser wunsch ist in erfüllung gegangen
wann endlich können die beiden die
schöne aussicht genießen
[Musik]
zurück in den kongo zu radio mein ding
der sender ist für eine woche
abgeschaltet worden
die beiden schweizer techniker sind
fieberhaft am arbeiten nur noch wenig
zeit bleibt bis radio meinte leo mit
einem komplett neuen studio wieder auf
sendung gehen soll
[Musik]
währenddessen ist hansjörg enz in das
dorf kuba unterwegs zu einer art privat
projekt mit eigenem geld und
spendengeldern finanzierte dort den bau
einer schule heute bringt der holz mit
mit dem ziel dass die dorfbevölkerung
gemeinsam die schulbänke für die schule
zimmert das ganze dorf ist auf den
beinen
hansjörg enz wird wie ein ehrengast
empfangen
[Musik]
doch standen gewusst und wie die ccc
hoch dass es nicht im vollen umfang hat
bis rechts erfolgt oder ob geworden ist
und thyrow worden ist und dann sieht man
mal ein die hier stellte er möchte und
ich hoffe den namensgleichen trotz also
den stand der zeit später 42 cad
anwendungen unterstützt findet man ihn
ja ich will es darf konstruktion machen
wir zu marvel uhr in der mall ist machen
wobei sie dabei können ja gesagt damit
billiger wird machen bereits fix
dachhaut echterdingen ruf und haben die
schachtel gemacht und gesagt so mächtig
und da jetzt irgendwie aufbauen
und da gibt es immer überraschungen er
zum beispiel mit größter sympathie
machen jetzt mal an bord ins ziel
goldstein und jetzt fällt ist aber noch
stützt sich einfach wieder hoch ich
freue mich jetzt mal wieder 700 stunden
unter dem motto keine betonieren und
dann wird erhoben welche die kriterien
einfach diese unterstützen das wenn man
dann halt machen es ist ein projekt sie
jetzt am anfang als wir zwei jahre diese
kosten
und dann geht es los hansjörg enz will
mit schweizerischer präzision gruppen
organisieren zum bau der schulbänke kein
leichtes unterfangen
ganz schön dass wir jetzt gebildet und
der gruppe mit seinem bahn gemacht aber
selbst herr schreiber dem serien wie
klingt das wirklich rücken
wir machen den banken den wahren
charakter bank das sind das
eingewechselte sam machten und die
fracht ins profil der gruppe
you know how
doch schließlich fangen doch noch alle
an zu arbeiten allerdings nicht nach der
gruppen methode von hansjörg enz sondern
einfach irgendwie und wie heißt es so
schön
am schluss ist es das ergebnis das zählt
[Musik]
doch immerhin
57 34 pcs menkens machen immer sie
enthält auch später modell welches
modell dorf gehe aber immerhin
funktioniert war für kritischen bericht
zu erstellen und hebel aus holz an die
agents hofft dass die neue schule in
einigen monaten eröffnet werden kann
[Musik]
bei sandra und danken gano in kanada
danken für seine herde
schon bald wird er einen großteil seiner
129 selber verkaufen verkaufen müssen
denn bis jetzt haben gar nur geld
ausgegeben
über eine halbe million franken haben
sie in ihrer farm investiert der verkauf
der kälber soll dringend benötigtes geld
in die kasse bringen fans einfach
schauen wir wirklich gut die tiere oft
sie dass die jetzt für preise ab ob er
das ist also vom ranking der brieskorn
fluss schauspieler zurück bevor das
mittel aber danken rechnet mit etwa
60.000 franken einnahmen davon müssen
sie bis ende des nächsten jahres liegen
können
auch darum ist es wichtig dass sandra
mit dem eigenen gemüsegarten einen
beitrag leistet zum haushaltsbudget auf
dem gemeinsamen konto herrscht schon
bald eben jetzt sind's noch rosig das
ist eigentlich völlig lange wurde zwar
ein guter monat der zwei monaten durch
bismarck alba verkauf und dann geht es
der große zahltag mit einem haarigen
sicher mango mit viel weniger muss durch
es ist einfach schwierig und mir war ich
nur maschine der fake buch schildere
satzteile und einfach schnell groß
rechnet für die banken und mehr
ausmachen als mehr brauchen als meter
lang aber es wird lange
[Musik]
in australien bei der familie schmid
diener kämpft mit den tücken der
englischen sprache sie befüllt für ihre
englisch prüfung
die braucht sie um als krankenschwester
arbeiten zu können
beim ersten anlauf hat sie die prüfung
nicht bestanden
das projekt machen glücklich machen
zwar läuft noch nicht alles nach wunsch
bei schmid umso mehr genießt die familie
aus dem sanktgallischen ruf wie die
wenigen momente als ganze familie denn
schon bald russ touristenführer cabot
wieder weg auf tour
wenigstens die vierjährige amira ist
rundum glücklich im kindergarten und der
sonnenschein der familie
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
in dubai sind die mädchen von macho nist
mittlerweile aus der schule zurück
celina macht ihre hausaufgaben die
schule in dubai bezieht die eltern stark
mit 1 assist communication buch home
school communication buch kann man
beseitigen schrieb american geschrieben
[Applaus]
dass bach linie punkt wo man nie das
auto finde aber ein großes ganzes tue
ich sehr gut
das sind mehr sachlichkeit das ist nicht
korrekt ich selber wo ich bin krieger
crooks tricia und grün oder schwarz grün
oder schwarz auf der trauminsel isla
margarita in venezuela macht claudio
candrian was er eigentlich nie mehr
wollte arbeiten
feuer feuer feuer
[Musik]
in der werkstatt eines schweizer
kollegen arbeitet er unterdessen fast
fünf tage pro woche und verdient sich so
einen zustupf von einigen hundert
franken pro monat
der ehemalige lokführer bei der rhb kann
das arbeiten einfach nicht lassen
[Musik]
also verließ der fahrer aber das ganze
drum und dran
das muss immer
die funktionäre für touristen sagen
natürlich vorteile holen und so
funktioniert halt natürlich bei weitem
nicht so wie in der schweiz
aber man lebt damit immer so da und
fertig zu hause in der mietwohnung
teresa erzählt vom größten schock ihres
lebens vor wenigen wochen sind nachts zu
den bündnern gekommen
richtig
todesmutig es nach draußen um die diebe
zu stellen
zum glück nur sehr streifschuss kräfte
die ganze geschobenen anfang an und iris
sagt sie habe an diesem geburtstag ein
zweites leben geschenkt bekommen und mit
der allgegenwärtigen kriminalität müsse
man halt leben lernen im kongo bei radio
ma in der leo ist heute der große tag
die letzten tests im neuen studio laufen
der schweizer ingenieur für die kohle
erklärt hansjörg enz die neuen geräte
[Musik]
und der zeitung neues material als
official says now ist redaktorin
mitzumachen wenn das in zehn tagen
abgefahren
der schimmel krömer hat und ich fünf
sekunden und die laufen sagt mit dem zug
fahren und will gleich selber
demonstrieren wie präzise man mit dem
neuen studio eine sendung machen kann
ständig sie mit der maus und als nächste
wie sich zeit mit mäßigen erfolg 14
monate hat hansjörg enz auf diesen
moment hingearbeitet
die freude der mitarbeiter von radio mal
in der leo sei belohnung genug für ihn
sagt der schweizer entwicklungshelfer
sie halten ihre versprechen bedankt sich
der direktor des radios bei hansjörg enz
in kanada bei garros sollen heute einmal
alle sorgen und probleme an land
gelassen werden
sandra danken nutzen den traumhaften
sommerabend für eine bootsfahrt auf den
lake manitoba dem see der irgendwie auch
ihrer ist
zeit einmal zurückzuschauen und bilanz
zu ziehen
[Musik]
meine lohnt wird so fall meine hand
ausreicht um verträumt hand und ich mit
dem wieder schaffen dass man da eher
glück sind und das erreicht womit den
rand es ist große herausforderungen das
würde alle liter herausforderung und es
geht er schon bereit zu rufen und aber
mit einer emotionen und tagesform
es gibt wirklich ganz gut das geht an
der theke durch 4425 dollar zum teil wie
es nervig und den musikern abschalten
dass ich jetzt so recht nichts zahlen
abhaken
also ich könnte ich wünsch mir ich hätte
die ist allein zum abschalten und so
wünsche ich mir du hast gut abschalten
[Musik]
in australien in alice springs besuchen
schmitz den reptilienzoo das leben im
outback birgt viele gefahren
die sollen die kinder von früh auf
kennenlernen
[Musik]
si
herbert spricht fast nur noch englisch
mit seiner tochter amira die angst dass
die cargo will ich mein sich das war
sagt das ist das lange schlagen und dann
kann die kleine amira diligence also die
echsen die sie so marc hautnah
kennenlernen
[Musik]
märz
denn
[Musik]
schwierige monate liegen hinter der
jungen familie
der schritt vom sankt gallischen rufe
nach australien war nicht immer nur
einfach dann finde ich sehr gut
entscheiden
es ist nach wie vor weit mehr geholt und
ich vermisse es durch allem für sich
unsere landschaft und auch immer nun
blüht ist immer gut aber man ist dann
fertig mit ali summieren könnten wir nie
wieder in excel haften ich sage nur
sendung ihren drei und das ist
landschaft klappt es hatte nur
forderungs die besonderheit des kangoo
ist es auch anders stichsäge so gut aus
in der bella mega unterseite sind
unkompliziert und und das macht sie
schon wieder fast allen verwandten seite
auch linie gestoppt ist und das ist so
genannte schmidt besetzten hier berühmt
in la hei
[Musik]
im wüsten emirat dubai wollenmann
johnnys ihre neue heimat einmal aus
einer neuen perspektive sehen
[Musik]
sonys sind beeindruckt aus einem kleinen
wüsten städtchen ist in wenigen jahren
eine über moderne wirtschaftsmetropole
geworden sie bildete in der photo by
vorteil
[Musik]
mühlacker
dazu kommt dass hat wenig frauen
bucher das wird das ist mehr ein sprung
direkt aus dem boot ins kühle nass
der wahre luxus auch monika mann juni
zieht eine positive bilanz so einen
schritt machen
nach der häme wenn die entschädigt dass
seine schritt machen
entschädigt ganz knapp für das duo bot
honda bistros probieren sie es nicht
wird man einfach wieder zurück ins
schwitzen
der vcd arbeitsplatz für meter hinaus
vor allem schon weiter zum strahlen
zum krönenden abschluss gibt der
bootsführer noch einmal richtig gas
mm
[Musik]
auch in venezuela auf der karibik insel
margarita präsentiert sich der
traumstrand von seiner besten seite
er ist nett und claudio candrian
genießen heute abend ein exklusives
teenie
[Musik]
venezuela ist nun so richtig die neue
heimat der beiden schweizer geworden
[Musik]
es ist doch schön einfach anders und
erfüllen die selber sowohl doch mit der
rwe hat und man muss endlich wieder für
wetter und so und jetzt konsolidiert ote
sieht und wo den euro als währung
kloster dunkel inspiriert khan im herzen
sie mir sehr leid genossen werden die
man eidgenossen blieben natürlich denken
wir machen ja nicht über 50 jahre
gewachsenen den cut alles einfach den
vermutlich meter oder anders private
note gut
[Musik]
5 auswanderer
alle sind sie auf und davon in die
fremde trotz allen widrigkeiten
irgendwie auch fünf erfolgsgeschichten
wir auf jeden fall wünschen den neuen
auslandschweizern alles gut